it into tom brady so it's funny and
you've always been and rightfully so i
am too
you have not heard your and you're not
from boston and you're not a patriots
fan you may be a
a patriots historian but not a patriots
fan
uh you're not from boston but you
appreciate tom brady as do i as the most
reasonable people
but i do want to ask you hey so clearly
we know how you feel about brady being
successful apart from the patriots
i did want to come to you as as even
though i lived in boston and my wife's
from the area and
started my career i love this feed item
i know where you're going i'm just
looking at you having your feed
totally disconnected from that community
now i got like my in-laws still live
there i got family there but i don't
know the pulse of that community the way
you still do um
why on earth would patriots fans
be bitter toward brady for
potentially going back to another super
bowl why
i don't know doesn't compute i don't
know and i don't
and i don't think all patriots fans are
some yes yeah what do you think the
split is
uh 35 are bitter
yeah i i still think that's too high
okay i think that's an accurate number
but i think that number is too high
this guy wanted to stay
he wanted to stay in boston he pretty
much
begged uh ownership and bill belichick
hey let me stay give me hook and brother
up with that drew brees contract and
we're good
give me two years 50 million we're good
and they didn't do it so he wanted to
stay
they declined and then they gave him no
choice
but to walk away so but even if that had
been the case even if he decided to walk
away
after 19 years so what
so wait just got clear the super bowls
but wait just so i'm clear you said he
wanted to stay
initially did i hear you right so so the
summer so before the
uh before the 2019 season
okay summer before the 2019 season
training camp
says all right contract's up i need a
new deal okay i'd like to get a new deal
what he's looking for is two years 50
million dollars yeah
what he did what he got was really not a
new deal it once
it was reported as a new deal but once
people started looking to say wait a
minute
tom brady's about to be a free agent
after the 2019 season what's going on
here he didn't get
that's not really a new contract he
messed around with some numbers he gave
him a little bit of a pay raise but
he's about to walk out the door that's
when he sells his house or puts his
house on the market
and brookline sorry we're not interested
you know a little
overpriced like 38 39 million dollars um
puts his house on the market is no
longer involved with his charity all
these other things
he wanted them to sign them up in the
long term
they didn't want to do it they wanted to
go in a different direction
there's no reason to be bitterson i
think there's no reason to be bitter
about
what what but what about all the he was
sick of belichick
and and wanted to change and didn't feel
appreciated
what about all that stuff i thought i
don't know i think i think all actual if
anything
okay it was mutual okay yeah because
belichick
look tom brady when you were covering
the patriots i don't know if people know
this
but people should they know the michael
smith story michael smith was covering
the patriots way back in the day we're
covering championship teams covering tom
brady bill belichick and stuff so when
you were coming to patriots
you remember tom brady being the first
one in
off-season workouts and he went some
special parking spot because he was some
workout warrior in the off season but
that was the
backwards hat wearing baseball cap
wearing
24 year old tom brady but when tom brady
got to be 40 putting on a grown man's
fedora
that's right they got a wife and kids
i'm a grown man
hey man i'm a grown man don't don't talk
to me like that in the meeting
don't talk to me like that i know the
offense
i'm gonna be prepared you don't have to
talk to me like you talk to everybody
else
and bill belichick would do he would
treat
brady just like anybody else and i think
some fans might say well that's right
don't make any exceptions everybody's
the same everybody's not the same
you can't treat tom brady like the 53rd
guy on the roster that's just absurd
so i think he wanted some
some relief from the
from the from the bellatic show at times
and and
it wasn't happening all i say is this
so it sounds like off the top you know
what you're basically getting at is like
if they're mad they mad at the wrong one
because they could have had him but the
hoodie let him go i would just say
i find that
and i've experienced this firsthand
you are bitter towards someone
or some entity when you
are not happy where you are
because like ooh this season peach dot
this season a seven and nine season is
foreign to new england
right as you know and if anybody out
there
feels some kind of way about watching
brady flourish
for another team for another franchise
flirt for another franchise
then i think it's really because you're
at home because you are at home
or you went home earlier than you're
accustomed to and worse than going home
earlier than you're accustomed to
you have no hope for the future at the
quarterback position
that's that's that's the simple so
basically like
you're watching your ex live his or her
best
life because you're at home single like
like you're alone and y'all broke up if
you had moved on
to somebody else if cam newton had
worked out the way we thought cam newton
work out when we were lauding the genius
of bill belichick once again in the
first couple weeks but everybody else
passed on on
on on cam newton except for belichick so
here they go again the patriots getting
the steal
catching everybody else slipping if cam
newton had thrown how many touchdowns
did he throw again this year michael i
forgot was it eight
was it ten did it eight the team threw
ten there you go
it was the team through ten he threw
weight is that correct yeah
and so okay another 11 rushing he
accounts for 19 touchdowns still
sure but if tom brady had not thrown for
twice as many touchdowns
exactly at a throne for twice as many
touchdowns
or accounted for what is that
five times as many passing touchdowns as
as the patriots starting quarterback
then i think those patriots fans who are
better would feel differently if i were
a patriots fan if i were
i would look at tom brady and just be
and just be proud and just say yeah we
taught him that
like he learned that he learned that
here even and not just that i agree with
you like
he's always going to be a patriot he's
always going to be remembered for being
a patriot
nothing he does with tampa would any way
cancel out
or make people forget or take away what
he did for 20 years
in new england so if i'm a new england
fan i'm trying to have it both ways i'm
trying to have it like oh our team at
home but my quarterback is going to the
super bowl again that's still my
quarterback
shout out to t.o that's how i'd be
looking at it
mike come on you everything you say is
correct
but why should it have to come to that
even
let's say you're doing poorly
let's say you don't win seven games
let's say you win three
without tom brady being there tom brady
gave you as as a sports fan
you can't get more than that from any
team i mean
there are nba teams that don't have
winning records
over 19 years there are nba teams that
don't do that
that year after year and it's it and
make the playoffs
uh x amount of years and to always be in
championship contention
you did that for a generation and so
when that comes to an end
how dare you be bitter what are you
bitter about what are you bitter about
it's supposed to is it was it supposed
to be 25 was it supposed to be 30 years
how long has it been to last that's a
crazy sense of entitlement yeah
and here's the other thing all right i'm
going through nfl history i know you're
a nfl historian you know all these
combinations
so whether it is bradshaw
and null whether it is montana and walsh
any great quarterback head coach
quarterback
combination there's no equivalent
to brady belichick that law yeah
yeah it's if you had gotten 10 years out
of them
you say thank you 12 a dozen years
wow this is a bonus yeah and not just
theirs
you you got it out of a six-round pick
it was you got it out of nowhere you got
it unexpectedly
you know what and it wasn't like also a
great point
a guy who spoke their language too
so a six-round pick who was a company
man
when it came to negotiating i always
used to say this about tom brady
i say tom you're the only one in new
england
who can sit there and say yeah i'm
holding out
i'm not getting enough money and the
fans you know fans usually hate when
players do that
yeah the fans would side with him he'd
have a case he's only gonna be like no
i'm not making enough
he could have made more money hey i
think it was
forbes forbes business a while ago did a
study and they
conservatively estimated that he left
about
anywhere between 80 and 100 million
dollars on the table
in his career 80 and 100 million dollars
wow what even when he was mad
at belichick he's sitting there with his
guy jim gray
he's mad at belichick and gray gives him
a you know
threw up threw him an alley said uh do
you feel appreciated by robert kraft and
bill belichick he's mad this is mad tom
brady you know what
you know what mad tom brady says hey if
kids are around
cover their ears i'm gonna tell you what
tom brady said get ready
i plead the fifth yeah
okay still mad at the boss yeah
yeah g right he would never take the
look he would always take the high roll
but never take the low road if he felt
compelled to take the low road he just
exit just get off all together
no listen i mean i i i'm picking the
packers
i love aaron rodgers part of me
a big part of me is pulling for brady
said no whatever pulling for brady to
get back to the super bowl in tampa i've
never seen a home super bowl
real quick note before we go to break i
was just going to say it feels almost
full circle
uh it feels almost full circle for
belichick it's not apples to apples it's
not the same thing
but it's almost bernie kozar like in
cleveland almost
you know very unpopular and he's not you
know for
driving the local icon out again i'm not
comparing kozar at that stage to brady
at this stage
but interesting how that kind of came
full circle in his career and speaking
of um
consistency talk about the more things
change um
i don't know if you saw gronk man you
know gronk
gronk's so used to going to championship
games
until he forget what conference he is
that's how much brady
is is automatic that's how that's that's
how custom you got to it
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you